my king was just so incredible I'm not
built like other men I can't SWAT team
because of his passion
I will keep you guessing and scared
scenes with him just felt really
authentic he was unbelievable at
capturing the idiosyncratic
psychological portrait of this
unpredictable personality when you're
doing a film with Rakim he comes alive
is evolving into
cut off the retreat
it's really amazing to watch him touch
the really dark places I could really
see him tapping into that kind of psyche
my destiny is n't powerful and I will
he's one of the best I found the crown
of the color I picked it up he placed it
atop my own head
[Applause]
Napoleon exclusively in movie theaters
November 22nd